[Music]
Around the world, farmers fight the same
battles. Battles against insects and
other pests that not only damage their
crops, causing high losses, but also
transmit diseases to millions of
livestock and humans.
At the same time, many insects are
becoming resistant to insecticides
while consumers are more aware of the
negative effects of pesticides on public
health, beneficial organisms, and the
environment. The sterile insect
technique is a type of birth control for
insect pests that does not harm
beneficial insects and the environment.
[Music]
Millions of males of the insect pest are
produced in special factories,
sterilized with radiation,
[Music]
and then released into the field at
regular intervals. There they mate with
wild females, and as a result, there are
no offspring. If sufficient sterile
males are released, the next generation
will have fewer wild insect pests and
the pest population can be controlled.
In situations of isolation, such pests
can eventually be eliminated.
Furthermore, if neighboring farmers
collaborate and coordinate by releasing
sterile insects together, large areas
can be effectively protected from such
pests.
There is no environmental pollution and
consumers can benefit from access to
food without insecticide residues.
With proven success in controlling
fruitfly and moth pests, this technique
is also being applied to livestock pests
and is being developed for mosquitoes,
making an important contribution to food
security and enabling countries to
compete in global food trade.
[Music]